this is a Fox News Alert the illegal
immigrant accused of killing a
California police officer has been
captured and we're learning this was not
his first arrest
good evening I'm Bret there the suspect
was caught just a few hours ago
near Bakersfield California after being
on the run for two days investigators
believe he's responsible for the murder
of Neumann police officer
Ron Hill Singh who migrated to the US
legally in an emotional press conference
late this afternoon the Stanislaus
County sheriff said Singh's death could
have been prevented all this happening
as we head into a long weekend with a
stalemate in the fight over border
security
we have Fox team coverage tonight from
Allison barbers at the White House where
the president is threatening to close
the US border correspondent Peter Doocy
is on Capitol Hill where members of
Congress are not but we began with
national correspondent William la
jeunesse who's following all the latest
developments from Los Angeles
good evening William well Bret just
hours ago police confirm the arrests of
33 year old Gustavo Perez Arriaga an
illegal immigrant confirmed gang member
and two-time convicted drunk driver with
outstanding warrants a California
sheriff also confirming the arrest of
two other illegal immigrants a brother
and co-worker who tried to cover up the
whereabouts of Arriaga as he allegedly
tried to flee to Mexico but under aerial
surveillance a Kern County TAC team
intercepted Arriaga
near Bakersfield where he surrendered
without incident Arriaga is the Mexican
national who entered the US illegally in
Arizona wanted for killing 33 year old
Ron Singh a 7-year Numan police veteran
who emigrated to the u.s. legally from
Fiji Singh was married with a five-month
old son he took this photo Christmas day
just hours before he and his canine
partner stopped a possible drunk driver
moments later seeing radios shots fired
I'm hit he died a short time later today
his brother Reggie thanked police for
finding the alleged killer he's not
coming back but
there's a lot of people out there that
misses it and a lot of law enforcement
people that I don't know don't work days
and nights to make this happen today in
the news conference the sheriff of
Stanislaus County threw gasoline on the
already red-hot immigration debate by
calling Singh's death preventable
blaming the state's sanctuary law for
prohibiting police from communicating
with ice about known and wanted felons
let's go back to Ron an immigrant
immigrated here lawfully and legally to
pursue his American dream he achieved
that goal and his dream was taken from
him no we shouldn't size it but we have
to have a conversation about restrictive
legislation that puts our communities at
risk when you tie our hands and don't
allow us to work with our federal
partners and communicate with our
federal partners about people that
commit crimes and who are in this
country illegally we're gonna have
instance like this police arrested three
more today for aiding and abetting and
say they are helping prosecutors build a
case against Arriaga arraignment likely
next Wednesday sings narcotics dog Sam
will be retired to live with his wife
and child